is underway with any longer oh no it
appears to be mr. Yu to himself shake we
are the Young Turks well known to work
[Music]
hey hey youtube you never got me down
you never got me down YouTube you never
got me down never got me down there
never get me down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's the sound of the weekend
because it's a Thursday live stream Oh
what's a we live stream I haven't every
we yet we have great guests we have
razor fists that's mr. razor fist with a
zero because he's cool but Clint Howard
on the show so he's insane and Owen
Benjamin with a song and of course
producer with me and video studio as
always is my faithful producer because
he's producing Jared who is not gay
follow him on Twitter not gay Jeremy
describe with your thoughts your
comments your photoshop's I fulfilled my
legal obligations as far as I know drawn
conclusions are we good we could
appreciate that Gerald Morgan simplified
wine.com
apparently can order one have a ship to
your door but why would you want to
unless your raging alcoholic add you
Morgan Jr what's the one of the day
we've got a bear Taj Zinfandel you start
more of a beer guy what did you like the
Bears Folsom Street Fair of course doing
overlays is that's FEM computer how are
you sir hello beep beep you can follow
me on Twitter at Elon Musk thanks for
foreshadowing soon we're going to be
talking about Elon Musk today I never
want to talk about everyone wants to
talk about the shooting the tragedy and
this is always sad when it happens it
happens on the show and then we hate
Nike and I'm over here you see what he's
doing he's looking at you you look at
everyone but me a beautiful show
sometimes cuz he gets emotionally
uncomfortable you know you wish what we
talked about by Elon Musk sucks let me
say that because I'm tired of always
having to deal with the political
mudslinging when it comes to public
shootings but that's your question of
the day comment below I genuinely want
to hear from you do you think that we
should do the class act just mourn those
who lost as we usually would have
throughout human history or are we
beyond the point of we no longer afford
that has the left forced us to fight
fire with fire
do we have to go tit for tat that's a
question I struggle with because a lot
of times we're looking old you're doing
the same thing well yeah I am but that's
because they're they're they're
politicizing the gun control issue
before the bodies are even close your
hand every time I don't know what do you
think I think you have to I hate having
to respond to these things like that but
you have to throw logic out there
because if people use emotion to make
laws we're gonna end up really screwed
in the end the United States America
okay Jared you know what set of ten
we've already done rebuttals with with
Vox because they had the biggest
anti-gun video
for a while with the young turks we've
done videos out there on the Second
Amendment whether it's meant just for
muskets they did the same thing with
freedom of speech we've done the gun
show loophole we've done so many videos
we've done so many shows where we've
dealt with the Australian gun buyback
the Canadian gun laws that I grew up
with so you know what I'm not gonna
revisit let's recap it and then we'll be
done with it because I know you're
dealing with this on every single other
show we can wonder why Elon Musk sucks
or something else because I'm tired of
the same conversation over and over set
your timer let's go assault weapons are
not an actual thing mass shootings are
on the decline the United States does
not actually have the most mass
shootings in the world all pistols are
some form of semi-automatic an ar-15 is
actually not a military weapon States
with the United States stricter gun
control laws and not statistically
reduced crime gun control matters at
large have actually proven to be not
effective in reducing violent crime the
United States by the way does not have
the highest violent crime rate in the
industrialized world most of the
statistical gun deaths that you actually
read about include suicides that's
something I didn't tell you gun by the
way gonna save millions more lives and
they ever take according to the FBI
anywhere from two hundred thousand to
three million plus by the way none of
this matters because the Second
Amendment ensures your right to
self-preservation period including
firearms period and yes that extends
beyond muskets to high-capacity guns
that were around back then like a Pelton
flintlock the public gun the Peckinpah
box revolver and by the way your toll
for exploiting this senseless tragedy to
try and forcibly strip us of our human
rights regardless okay
on what the show does that about cover
it I think that's a big pieces of human
shape if I could stand up and clap right
less than a minute that's pretty good
you can skip the entire CNN dialogue
we've covered all of that we've covered
every watch this AC worry your reference
mister internet skeptic do some research
guys then yourself I'm so tired of the
gun what bothers me is that is the
grandstanding the political
grandstanding the virtue signaling is
that they have the moral high ground
when their very position is evil and I
mean that is it no it's evil to disarm
law-abiding citizens what people call
something like what gives you the right
what who in the hell do you think you
are because someone did something bad
you think that you now have the right to
strip me of my god-given right to
self-defense
that's the problem with people countries
like Europe sorry spend computer that's
the problem with countries that don't
reckon
your rights coming from somewhere else
other than government sorry you get the
angry skeptic atheists mad and guess
what the Constitution recognizes it
rights were bestowed to us they were
bestowed upon us by God not by
government but these people don't
believe that they think they gave you
the rights that's why they think they
can take it away they think they can
tell you can't defend yourself because
something did something mean on a school
property
you know what it's terrible and it sucks
and I wish we could just say it's
terrible and it sucks I knows we could
just say God what an awful tragedy can't
we worn as a nation and the left talks
about coming together and finding common
ground how about you find common ground
shut your mouth and let the bodies be
buried before you push bulk legislation
that you know won't do anything and you
don't even abide by by yourself all
right in Olympic news
what's the outdoor sign pickets they're
out the Jamaican bobsled team coach has
just quit and she's taking the team sled
with her this comes to us from CBS
Sports the all-female bobsled team was
revealed in a series of first that's the
big thing got a series of firsts oh nice
first female Jamaican bobsled team like
come on but just days before their South
Korean debris that Sandra Curie Karis
Asus I have it right here
anyway former gold medalist for Germany
sure yeah but Germany has to import
their bombs that coaches Twitter post at
the helm of the team staff and she's now
threatening to keep the sled claiming
legal ownership so naturally this isn't
the news a team's very upset and
apparently they've been issuing veiled
threats to their former coach which is
already prompted Disney to purchase the
film rights [ __ ] why you running they
didn't know s.o.s locked it right off
that's the Canadian version and I think
she would already take in the sled but
she couldn't find a man to push it I
guess say you had an ax story they
wouldn't they asked the lady yes lady
yeah yeah she she had something to say
about her the sled and she responded my
not saying it I love is the actual
German yes yeah in her defense she only
knows two words mine and udin so she's
pretty here
the FBI language is now investigating a
funeral home for allegedly running a
side business selling body parts how to
make that money the federal inquiry
began several months ago shortly after
Reuters interviewed a half dozen workers
who formerly worked for Hess you notice
what he's actually not illegal I was
saying I guess there's nothing against
selling it for like medical expert oh
yeah I don't know something along you
can't sell your own organs but I guess
fire someone else officials they said
their suspicions were first raised at
court like without Capone as always
accounting discrepancies that's how they
caught it but it was later confirmed
when they saw the BOGO pancreas closeout
that was what tips it'll define oh
you're sorry to me it's never concerning
to me when a business minded person
fills a market it always concerns being
when I discover there's a mark or
something I never think there should be
I'm rocket for yes exactly that's what
concerns me
yeah these guys market for their lists
typically yes but other than that like
who's buying this I know someone who
won't be an org are you this is another
question of the day along with my first
one yeah are you an organ donor I know
some people say they don't wanna be an
organ donor because they think they'll
have the paddles like yeah that's true I
am a donor dang it to see if I was a
donor oh that's right you have the
wallet for a while I wasn't because he
can't be bothered carrying a wallet like
a man Iran has accused the west of using
lizards to spy on them this comes from
The Times of Israel the former chief of
staff of Iran's Armed Forces said
Tuesday that Western spies have used
lizards to attract atomic waves and spy
on his country's nuclear program the
lady doth protest too much nothing to
see here I think in Iran get any more
pair
my
put it pretty only agitator we'll deal
with it later can this officials have
now come out and said that guys it's
okay let's put up put on your game face
smile for the cameras Kansas officials
say this dog can't run for governor yeah
this is a real story the dog thought he
was a shoo-in because there
unfortunately for him his urine sample
did so Nick Nolte / Gary Busey of dogs
what if he just ends in a proper reveal
worried more trying again my yearbook
and I know it was weird looking back it
wasn't sweet Dyson I will say this my
wife will love this one because my wife
loves Dyson vacuums well someone's
saying are you saying yeah my wife does
actually I vacuum but my wife does most
of the vacuuming namely because I forced
her Dyson plans to bring a premium
electric car to market by 2020 this
comes from CNET the car is initially set
to feature solid-state batteries
technology in which I guess Dyson
they've been investing heavily now if
they can bring this technology to market
first it'll actually give em a huge leg
up on more established competitors I'm
sure you can guess thanks to the solid
state batteries higher energy density
and I guess that recharges more quickly
versus standard wet cells in other news
and what some people have seen as a
response
Elon Musk has announced his latest space
vacuum it's got a cup holder - a cup
holder only cost fourteen billion
dollars yeah I don't what well you were
saying something about the vacuum it
doesn't make any sense in space there's
an atmosphere right what do you tell me
there's no atmosphere in space they
still could have something to vacuum
well yeah but I mean that this no that
can't suck anything and doesn't know
nothing to work on right you mean no
force to work against yes
I mean there's still pressure but you
could create like a centrifuge
essentially feel like inside the back
vacuum right
I don't know this thing I don't know
well I mean let's say you go down to
different pressure in the ocean right
you still can keep a relatively
consistent pressure and we're talking
about space though yeah but they would
still I mean they could well they would
have to have some kind of a gasket I
mean they they vacuum don't they vacuum
stuff up in the in the spaceship in the
ship yes because they have some
atmosphere in the ship
yeah it's artificial
so you meant in this okay that makes
sense then okay in the spaceship beeping
outside do you think yeah it's just
vacuum when vacuuming
why wouldn't a q many thing outside a
spaceship well the photoshop look like
that just back hearing like the space
trash it's not factually accurate it was
a magazine spread from Tesla scaring
people off their money sorry we really
crossed wires there this is off to a
fantastic start you know it's funny
actually because you were the one who
really you can't stand Elon Musk and he
made news last week what was it because
of the launch of us is it the Space Act
I think they launched a new [ __ ] heavy
missile okay very sick so what what
happened with it was a it was a it
failed right because of the do you guys
know I don't know it was a Tesla RV it
wasn't a header it
what was it headed to the asteroid belt
and so it was supposed to know them the
middle Busan was supposed to land that
crashed and then it was supposed to go
to Mass beep-beep
supposed to go to where mas Mouse to
correct himself okay and instead oh
that's right and then yeah and then
instead what happened it when it's on
course to the asteroid belt right so
it's gonna crash that's I guess the
computer has no clue okay here you know
what I don't know how do you feel that
Leon musk I don't I think he's a dick I
I know everyone loves Elon Musk I think
I'm in the minority here it's like it's
like it's like people were saying the
Godfather is the best film ever right
I think Chinatown was the better movie
that year I think the guy father's fine
it's like Carol Burnett I don't find
Carol Burnett funny I'm in this small
minority I don't like Elon I don't find
the stuff he does that cool you know
this is we went to LA and the one guy
that might you bridge I was just like
just fawning over the new Tesla Model 3
it looks like a Ford Focus with the
facelift crap I get it but at some point
like I love guys that throw out crazy
audacious ideas right so that part of it
I like that's fine just other part I
don't government subsidy fund projects
that would never like to stand on if it
weren't for billions of dollars right
and that's the debate in that debate
right there right so engineers calling
him an idiot for tunneling and stuff
like that or whatever I which he might
be well he could very well be but hey go
go like test that's a good example it's
Elon it's the electric car okay
it's basically way to scam the
government out of money and let's
celebrities rich
people virtue signal with their electric
cars without government subsidies Tesla
would employ I think sales and Denmark
went down about spend commuter can bring
this up sixty percent once they started
phasing out the tax breaks there you go
from Bluebird so the government was a
Tesla and I talked about this what's the
the Prius back when I did a video at
PJTV in 2009 it was still losing Toyota
yeah money on everyone sold and it was
the most profitable hybrid vehicle at
that point yeah I think the Nissan Leaf
was a similar story was it yeah there's
only a subsidies I don't think it really
made the main well the story with the
Prius a lot of people not remember there
were a lot of other hybrid cars at that
point now yeah but the Prius is the only
one that was a driving guilt token you
know so they wanted to drive it there
were other there was basically the Honda
Civic Hybrid but you didn't get the
street cred Oh he drives a Prius he must
really have human oh by the way every
single person who can't drive got
together in Los Angeles and picked the
Prius as their car just worry about the
Tesla because you got liberals crazy
good but that you see ones driving
around you're like I know the guy isn't
the 1% yes that's that's what's
important because let me sort of set the
stage the government is taking taxpayer
money they're giving it to rich people
as a reward for purchasing these
pretentious I know they're fun to drive
I've heard they're fun
$7,500 rebate from the federal
government right on the purchase price
and I think some states like California
it's $2,500 or more they can add it up
to their own by the way like you said
the average household in you know the
average household income of a Tesla
owner has the owner Tesla model probably
Electra model 10 Model X is one and then
model 3 is the one that just came out
it's a big big deal I guess I don't know
okay five hundred and three thousand Wow
yeah where's Bernie I need help two men
where is Bernie next campaign should be
503 didn't buy as much as you think in
LA no it doesn't it doesn't it does not
buy as much pittance namely you're just
getting stabbed and you're 503 being
taken for pretty much yeah so then there
was a Solar City project the Solar City
reportedly received I think it's close
to 500 million dollars 490 something
millions fanless bring it up indirect
grants from the Treasury Department Wow
the cost of the government would be a
total of somewhere around between one
and two billion that was one point five
billion dollars I don't have it in front
of me I know Sven does do your jobs
phone computer which would include
Treasury grants paid to solar city
directly
sex everyone loves to talk about space
excuse me I'm not a huge fan of that you
want must thing because I think there's
a house of cards if you want to talk
about some guy being a brilliant there
are people who are brilliant
entrepreneurs or people who create
products and services that people want
they make their money and then there are
people who find a way to game the system
and I would say half a billion dollars
in direct government correct you're kind
of gaming the system
SpaceX same thing more government
subsidies about 20 million in economic
development subsidies from Texas to
construct the launch facility there and
then I think separate from whatever from
incentives SpaceX they've gotten is it
something like five point five million
over five billion over five billion in
government contracts that's a big thing
is you never know some of those
contracts are no bid
but contracts these are from NASA all
the way up to the Air Force overall you
have Musk's Empire never I get it I'm
gonna get tech people who are mad at me
I'm not saying I wish the guy I wish the
guy ill will at all but his empire has
taken in over five billion dollars from
the government it's not the same as it
even invented a mousetrap you say
government you mean you yeah I was gonna
say and that's that's where the argument
comes so do you some of these things I
would make the argument on some of the
big things that nobody else is gonna do
this right and you would probably
disagree with me right so like on the
SpaceX stuff or on the the big expensive
project sometimes it has to be like
going to the look at other government RG
right well look at fracking right but
those aren't incredibly cost prohibitive
like something right like going but you
can sell it immediately he's going to
space for a long time not any money but
the government basically made it so they
were the only ones who could do it right
yeah and then other enterprises do it
better but we subsidize stuff like oil
right now and coal and things like we do
now but that's because it was ultimately
the government trying to hitch its wagon
is something that is already profitable
that already works the market will
determine that yeah it is profitable
there is oil well country of people
think it's actually possibly a very
renewable resource and we're certainly
not running out of her that term peak
oil yes already happened it's not a
thing I don't know I don't agree with
you I mean think about this for a second
someone at some I think if something is
useful people will figure it out someone
at one point looked at a pineapple on a
tree and said I can jam that in my mouth
Phil I don't disagree I'm just saying
how
would it would it take a lot longer or
it does that mean that it just shouldn't
happen right it doesn't take very long
at all if you're a socialist such as
yourself I'm not a socialist he is a
socialist we we actually have a scoop we
have a scoop and we're very blessed and
so I know it's not not necessarily the
best intro but maybe you can clear a few
things up here to discuss this directly
is mr. Elon Musk himself mr. musk can
you hear us
of course theme I have two fast internet
in the world that me don't that make
sense so thrilled to have you here
mostly uh but it wouldn't be fair of me
if I didn't toss you a few hard balls
off the bat I hope you understand of
course it's great first how would you
respond to the critics who say that your
company has essentially relied on
government funding that's been a bit
disparate it's a common criticism but
what people often miss is that in fact I
make more money yeah yeah but you see
that's the problem you're taking it from
the taxpayer and claiming it as profit
but I meant more money there no that's
not profit it doesn't even include
willing investors that's just my money
no see maybe I'm not taking my money you
see me Elon Musk with all these
subsidies how many more minutes I
totally get where you're coming from but
I'm changing the world here like for
example right now wouldn't you like to
explore the outer rings of Jupiter Wow
you know actually if I think if we're
being honest that yeah that does sound
like something I might wanna because
that project right now is in development
stages and we are accepting
contributions and okay I think I think
we're done here we're done
launching we're also accepting private
contributions now okay and how much of
that cost I won't send you this envelope
right yes a return and place some stamps
on it that you have to get yourself and
your contribution and then your
convention Elon Musk everybody not to
period please I don't know what I
expected Elon Musk only thinking of
numero uno we'll be right back after
this with razörfist and Clint Howard
I mean I know I gotta accept your ass
but I'm telling you right now these
people keep flying us I'm gonna sue
something but go ahead and see everybody
you're tough guy goes to people so not
get your super bra
so YouTube sue me why Adam what like it
you can yourself Twiggy ya fat [ __ ] look
at you but understand what do you mean
sue you me
sue me stop dear do me a big favor you
drive me [ __ ] crazy you get a lawyer
or something your Big Shot just sue sue
me but what do you mean by you though so
what's that mean don't spank a pity you
don't even know what you meant
you mentioned YouTube Bob Ross and you
you included yourself with them you
could have mentioned anybody but you put
yourself in with them you really let
these losses you in your lap they did a
real Japanese
you know Ignatz yeah but what that to
you you flag my video what you flag my
video how could you ask me a question
like that
I'm your researcher oh yeah you asked me
yeah well you get the boats big enough
to ask me now just tell me I'm not
answering it I'm not gonna answer that
stupid you know you're very smart fake
computer you give me all these answers
but you're not giving me the right
answer I'm gonna ask you again
did you or did you not I'm not answering
it it's a sick question you're sick
[ __ ] I'm at that stick that I want
your answer nothing anything only soft
knock a jerkwad taro and Tom I'm not
staying in his nose with you you sick
bastard look at you really feel sorry
for you you know what I should do to try
and lower my writing and a little less
eating maybe then you'll get less
insults in the comment section you sick
[ __ ] maybe then you'll stop taking on me
you'll never allows you understand your
[ __ ] back oh you're cracking up
screwball you
[Music]
[Music]
our next guest I refer to him as mr.
fist mr. fists I came on twitter at
razor fist with a zero right with the
zero with is your no and then his and
then his YouTube is was it is it /c /
rageaholic mr. fist do we have that
right the flesh see / why this is are
you trying to make it impossible for
people to find you it's because of Susan
were fragile istic expialidocious see
she's our next guest actually in the
form of Clint Howard
yeah no I don't you can't shake I mean
that was your decision at some point you
chose that and then you then they
wouldn't let you change it yeah my
audience they'll find me they'll find me
sorry guys I would have had more
presentation going on I figured to
adequately convey the tact and lack of
political politicization from BL left in
the aftermath of yesterday's tragedy I I
considered dressing like an ar-15 today
yes
you know I think I think that would have
been great you could have been like a
little driving dance let's all go to the
lobby
this is monetized this will be monetized
with cars we just I just ranted at the
beginning of this because I didn't want
to talk about everyone's talking about
it and we've you know we've debunked Vox
we've debunked the Young Turks in the
topic we've gone specifically through as
a second Amendment just for muskets
we've gone specifically through free
speak on stitute there is not much more
to say about it if you don't know where
you line up on this issue someone doing
something means shouldn't change it but
here we are the same conversation again
here's my question you actually my
question of the day was do you think
should we just do the class act and just
just mourn those lost or do you think
the less has just we no longer can
afford that luxury and we have to go tit
for tat I think there honestly the
PlayBook is getting so thin at this
point I mean they even reused the
hashtag did you notice that you notice
the the hashtag gun control now and of
course that was was it a retread yes it
was from the last time whenever the Las
Vegas thing I figure oh god yeah and it
was of course co-opted immediately by
ninety percent of the country that
actually possesses a prefrontal cortex
so gun reform
yes exactly
yeah euthanasia is just it's good it's
it's giggle gas it really is you know I
I will say it this sounds terrible you
just want to come out and say you know
thoughts and prayers or whatever it is
there my condolences that's what you
want to do but you can't you can't
because before we even say hey my
condolences to the
and Elizabeth Warren is there being a
[ __ ] it's right away it's so immediate
there's not even like a rest in peace
the victims hashtag they just jump right
done before gun control you know
whatever and you click on any of these
hashtags and not since the Human
Centipede of this many heads been jammed
in this many it's just thing I
understand obviously the physicality
they were they were sown but I get that
it's allegorical I understand it was you
know Jim or a guy who I know is a film
buff I know you
I appreciate made of course erasers has
a whole list of metaphors you just check
them off he's checking them off the list
pinky Winky with the magic bag yes
exactly
well you know what it isn't did you know
what actually I found out was in that
bag was very surprised
I don't usually are you a firearm owner
yourself I think you've been pretty open
about your position on this issue yes
sir yes sir there's a revolver hanging
up behind me and I got a mauser c96
sitting over there and I may have an
antique firearm aficionado but what kind
of revolver I can't see it what kind of
a rover do you have there it's a 45
ruger blackhawk it's a single-action
okay that's not really an antique but it
is a nice it is a nice piece old school
style single-action it was the first gun
ever shot that was the first fire in my
ever shot I was 18 or 19 because in
Canada you know no things fun are
allowed and I shot a ruger blackhawk and
I shot a Glock 19 and I much preferred
the Blackhawk I just fit my hand better
that's why I was a big revolver guy
until until the Walther those were
really the first sort of they're
obviously super organ ama cand they're
sponsored of the show now but outside of
those I typically feel better with a
revolver I think maybe contoured to your
hand is what I love about it it's one of
the reasons I like the Mauser is the
only automatic that I have is because it
kind of has a revolver ish kind of grip
it's got that broom handle grip that's
why they call it weight the mousers not
an automatic is it no you mean you mean
it's the first automatic it's the
machine pistol but do you get did you
get a specific license for that or did
you
yeah is it no I'm an Arizona man Arizona
in Vermont they don't care ironically
enough Vermont is the only other state
game believe as liberal gun laws as
Arizona is Bernie Sanders home state yes
it is remarkable and one thing I will
say have you noticed like you said their
playbook is getting really tired it used
to be so the gun control was a single
most losing issue for the left and then
there'd be a shooting and they'd see a
bump but I don't think they're seeing
the bump anymore
just began I think it's wrong the media
because of the internet the information
is so available the information tells
the tale really is this is a story that
is entirely factually based when you
talk about gun control and their numbers
just do not add up but first time that
people are almost unwillingly exposed to
other ideas right about how good that
would actually go out do you like people
you know bitching about a ban or
whatever which I can understand I'm
giving the sweeping success of the drug
ban in this country Jesus you can't find
opioid in the Midwest share his Twitter
account by the way so much help
we never got more hate mail than share
remember that one day we had a guy
tweeting us don't you ever make fun of
share and he tweeted us his share wall
and I was like first up that guy's a
[ __ ] but then I was like this guy's it
was a it was a wall of share no joke oh
I'm pretty sure she was made of xanax
[Laughter]
yeah exactly she's I think that's what
she's she would Morse but she can't
because of the Botox with his blink cuz
I can get out she's there's someone
she's in the back of her brain and
someone has hijacked her body
um yeah he's half the messaging no you
go ahead I was gonna
something completely useless the
messaging and a half it's like they just
blow me over with the people that make
the point guard for these issues right
you know it's like to make the case for
comprehensive birth control like sham
care whatever they reanimated Pelosi too
so Obamacare like does anybody take a
look at that maybe fleshie calls a face
and think yeah she is a product of the
product this is like a person walks in
and go yeah okay you know what she seems
to have her stuff together I've always
maintained I never got a lot of flack
I've said Nancy Pelosi I think is the
worst human being in American politics
ever far worse and Hillary Clinton
people could at the time everyone said
no no Hillary Clinton I'm going I get
that she's running for national office
so she's a more consequence as far as it
was the worst human being in American
politics ever in the history of it I
can't think of anyone worse than Nancy
she won't go away it's like she just
finds a new way to stick her nose and
she's been around since since forever -
she's not just a modern politician she's
been around since the 70s she was part
of that whole the California cabal
during the Jonestown stuff and the Jim
Jones
suicide and all that you know the Jerry
Brown she's part of that all kind of
million or whatever what she just keep I
think somebody died a long time there's
somebody with a 3d printer just
manufacturing Morton Hinton Pelosi same
guy who's very King
she's like the Tupac hologram I think
with Nancy Pelosi she's emblematic of
the Democratic Party where if you like
you said she's been around so long so
it's actually a great timeline
she just consent any new further left
position she takes if you go back she
about how dare you compare gay marriage
to the transsexuals and bathrooms and
now it's like well of course we have to
have transsexuals and bathrooms if you
were to go back how dare you compare the
idea of Plan B to a 20-week abortion
then you go fast-forward 10 years
well of course we need
26 week abortions so it's just it no
matter what it is they've got to take
the furthest left view that's even on
the table that's what the DNC is and
Nancy Pelosi has done it every single
time without fail do you think with the
gun control issue it could be leading to
an implosion or do you think we could
California talking about Nancy Pelosi
who does she represent as the San
Francisco area
I mean look that's what gets me where do
they consider comprehensive gun reform
like California with the magazine
restrictions like every time I say two
rounds and fires confetti and flags my
brother a gun in California so this is
true story I tried to give him one of my
old for my sig p9 38 now the reason was
because Dean Cain has a sig p228 people
don't know that's the 380 equivalent
exact same gun this is a 9-millimeter
couldn't send him any Walthers no
Walthers are not available in california
except for the 22 so i found out the
best way they said we can do this and
deliver it to his LLC turns out the sig
p9 38 isn't available and it's just a
time thing it's the exact same gun has
the same kind of internal safety
mechanisms it is a different caliber but
that's not why it's basically after a
certain point in California you cannot
get a firearm on the approved list so
people have just stopped trying so there
you go you're just gonna be I mean if
ever there's a civil war california is
going to have guns that are outdated by
about 20 years we take them first and
then move our way and you know Nevada
Arizona three times a week or like what
what is going on over there in
California yeah exactly it's like what's
like to think it mainly is the magazine
restrictions though it's just I mean it
wouldn't
that they have abated forums it would be
that they're done after two shots it's
ten rounds and what's funny is I
remember this rumor I bought when we
were Michigan the cz-75
so I bought a cz 75 funnel if I got the
only cz 75 in the world that was
unreliable because they're great guns
and when I bought it it had all the
California magazines now let me tell you
it's the exact same firearm only there's
a dimple underneath it so the firearm
would typically fit 15 plus 1 now it
only fits I think 9 plus 1 and I was
sitting there going by the way it came
with like six so I'm going I'm going oh
you know ok Hall second 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 button who could possibly figure
this out I mean it's so silly it is just
it defies logic completely and I know
people say that a lot it's like it's
become a meme like if you're a liberal
you're a special kind of stupid with Sam
Elliott and I hate that because this is
one of those issues where it really
defies logic there's no losing so bad on
it yeah let me say trite you know
homilies like it's easier to buy a gun
than it is to vote thank you
I don't need an ID I don't even need an
ID to vote and I need an ID I know I
know I had that when I went to voice an
ID like no no don't joke to me don't
joke to me I was about this yesterday
though I mean if you were to given the
same psychopath kid how about two
revolvers it would have been almost
exact same scenario gave him my
lever-action 357 that thing with its 13
rounds in there of 357 cutting out of an
18-inch barrel you have an idea how how
much damage that can do give him the 10
round ultimately it comes down to they
wanna ban guns they know that a 10 round
magazine that can be swapped out just as
quickly isn't gonna be the difference
between live saved or lost I think they
have four ar-15 versus a Glock 19 yeah
they're already have you seen we're only
writing the true return the mental
illness banned p.s oh you mean
to be weaker version of the Florida law
that already didn't catch that kid right
just put this kid in an FBI database
that literally gets used for absolutely
nothing
base like the Isis kill list when I had
the FBI they said but they said don't
worry by the ISIS killer's pretty much
everyone's on the ISIS kill list have
you ever said Isis sucks
you're on the ISIS kill list that's
pretty much the FBI watch list as it
relates to gun owners all right we have
to go mr. fist that is razörfist with a
zero on YouTube because Susan Wojcicki
hates you /c / the rageaholic anything
coming up people should be looking for
yeah I'm gonna be storming this Friday
that's what I'm gonna be doing okay and
then we have own Benjamin I believe at
some point we have oh we have Susan
Wojcicki ness whiskey coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you doing I didn't I think what
make sure it's that big oh yeah now we
sell 3x in 4x4 burly men or women Yeah
right so who is like the person you want
to see in these like the most with the
least likely to put one honey
Amy like on three yeah are you ready all
right 3 2 1 Michael more gelato with
Crowder shop calm shirts are now
available in 3 X + 4 XL for the burly
man in you
[Music]
this was a little bunny foo foo I don't
know from Lam chances just do this
grieving all the field mice and boppin
em on the head you're like my god that's
a violence such a jerk honey you know
what
one that before we bring our next guest
I was just watching White Fang with my
wife the other night I'd really liked it
and then last night we watched Billy
Elliot I'm not gonna lie I cried that's
one that always really really touches me
but we watched White Fang and you
realize you're supposed to you care
about the wolf he becomes friends with
the wolf
yeah but the wolf is killing mice and
rats and the wolf like goes after this
bear so we're supposed to hate bears and
mice but then ratatouille comes out and
you're supposed to keep out the mouse
and then there's there's elbow was a big
bear and you supposed to care but you
just realized that Disney just make so
whichever animals and that film is who
you should care about and screw
everybody else until the next franchise
comes out I just wanted to go out what
to do them all I feel all Bears hey
speaking of Hollywood and Disney our
next guest probably the biggest
definitely the longest resume of anyone
on this show I think so not even close
not even close even with when we get
George W Bush on this show Clint Howard
how are you sir good and I like the new
I like the new dance the admin move I'll
tell you what you're bringing nuance to
that that's really spectacular yes I am
free laughs how about the motivation yes
it's all about the motivation hey before
we have you ever done have you ever had
a method to acting because you know I've
I've acted for a long time I just did
this Raging Bull parody here and so for
me for impressions I've had kind of a
method that I've developed myself but as
far as when I would just go in and do
films you remember there was a Chubbuck
theory was really big for a while your
scene motivation you're over all right
yeah
chubby what yeah the Chubbuck theory was
really big it was Halle Berry and ever
men I don't know that Clint you're
supposed to know oh no no no no no I
know I mean that somebody's a man take
their method out or this person Ivana
Chubbuck I think imagine be mrs. Chuck
Bott probably a tough life unless you
have people do your but what about you
when you would when you would act you
get
roll what do you what do you do for it
how do you prepare for it it's just very
organic or are you do you have a spoke
method well wait it yet
it's got to be organic and there are
technical aspects of being an actor that
you have to kind of follow and know what
you can and can't do physically but my
dad who you know we just had his
memorial just to love this past weekend
and that grants our and he was my mentor
and my sage and he taught me acting in
just you know he there's only about five
things you really need to know okay and
what is you need to listen to the other
actors yep and listen to everything
that's going on you need to have a
motivation you need to know where you're
going and where you've been there you go
literally spend easy
remember not get a rose tone spend that
did we get him to act playing Joe Pesci
and I said think of where you're ending
up and and then kind of follow through
to that because he's getting caught with
the words a lot of first-timers does
what they do when you walk into a room
into a situation you have an intention
right yeah I mean it might be mindless
or it might be a goof but you have
intentions so it's just a matter of dad
explained to both Ron and I you know you
have to understand where your character
has been and I don't mean you know in a
esoteric way literally right you know
was like when I was little it was was
like just in school was I just playing
with you know whatever it's just so that
that is is mission-critical also simply
enough be there early right and be fair
the last time I checked they call it
professionalism you know it's just a
matter of you know there's an
expectation of employment and that is
giving them a fair day's work or your
pay speaking for so do you if your TV on
is that what I'm hearing no okay never
mind somebody back it's it's just the
NSA that isn't
they're cool yeah well tell me this you
know because I never want to be
exploitative at all but you mentioned
you wanted to talk about it
your father's memorial you know if I can
say off air you said you know you were
kind of you weren't dealing with it
necessarily in the best way your
father's passing which it caught me off
guard because we spent a lot of time
with you and everyone here really got to
know you and really felt like I mean
everyone here really got to know you is
to love you since like wow I mean he's
you're you're quirky don't get me wrong
but you were incredibly lucid and and
very positive so it's it's surprising to
me I I'm sorry to hear that it's been so
tough I hope you're doing well and I
know I just had the memorial I my mom
died about what 18 years ago and I was
the first time I had been around in any
anybody who passed that I kind of had
any relationship with it all right
um and then I didn't do that well I felt
that I didn't grieve I don't think I
grieved in a healthy way it took me a
long time to grieve and you know and
then well Ron and I have talked about
this and dad dying I was here I found
him when he had fell ill and was taken
to the emergency room and so you know I
didn't do that well I didn't blow it I
didn't you know go to jail or I didn't
cause any trouble I just felt like I
should have been either a little more on
top of it or a little more together and
you know just before dad died and I knew
he was gonna pass it was just I I had
said my goodbyes and I just it popped
into my head he goes you know Clint
I don't do dying parents well I didn't
have great last bedside conversations
with my dad or my mom I look mother
scope of my spirit magma skull did look
I think wonderful experiences with my
parents and I've got experiences that
I'm gonna cherish with me it's just at
the end it wasn't really Pleasant right
now and I I don't like to seeing
somebody laying in a hospital bed you
know
dime well we're dead let me say if it
means anything you seem to be handling
yourself incredibly well of course with
your your significant other won't name
names I think I know you keep your
private life private but she was she was
lovely and you were both out here as a
couple and we really enjoyed our time
with you and if there's ever anything we
can do and I mean I know you know we
mean that you talk with our Booker
Darren my dad all the time a matter of
fact I have semi nude pictures of you
which you sent to him keep doing that
next time make them fully nude yeah
please
you know what I was actually thinking
about one of those men's undergarments
that are they rhyme it's kind of a saw
you know saying us yeah yeah yeah I
thought about sort of finishing the bit
today with that sort of action with with
the customized in fact actually one note
of kind of sadness was on Christmas my
girlfriend gave me this this sock
underwear and I it was I just read her
butt out of hanging the stocking by
chimney with care so I had the great
moment with her it was fine and I
literally reached for my phone to call
my dad because the first guy I gotta
tell that I got one of these is my pop
cuz he would have gotten a huge kick out
of it and it wasn't so much that I
thought about it is I literally felt
myself reaching for my phone right and
you know I don't beat that don't beat
myself up over that it's just you know
it it's all something we did that most
of us have to go through beat yourself
up over any of it you know it's funny I
beat myself we're not even talking
politics or any of this right now but
since we kind of we got into this
territory I was talking with with Johnny
boy from Canada our new manager here the
other day about this the first person I
ever had who died close to me was my
grandfather and she was just I mean just
an incredible guy always talked about
this he was poor he was effectively a
glorified super but the guy who owned
the building
mr. mojo was a millionaire which in
Montreal was unheard of and he was the
exact same size as my grandfather so he
would give him his suits so my
grandfather would be smoking his black
and milds cigarillos the little wooden
tipped cigarillos in a three-piece suit
always with rubber boots mind you over
his nice shoes elbow deep in crap
cleaning toilets - the day he died
carrying in a three-piece suit Clark
Gable stache Brylcreem
he had several puddles of Brylcreem in
his cabinet hair slicked back I mean
it's just an incredible character was
very well people said like a second
father
he lived two houses two apartment
buildings down so was it was less than
50 feet away and everyone he was this it
was very it was very sudden that was the
last person he spoke with it was at pray
Ville elementary school we used to do a
ski trip the very last day before
Christmas so his December 18th I believe
and I remember waiting at school and he
was always want to come pick me off my
parents were about my mom was working
downtown she was a costume designer and
there was some kind of maybe festival
going on and I remember waiting for my
grandfather I didn't come I said okay he
they said he's caught up doing something
which was odd because he would always be
there and then they told me uh your
cousin house is coming and she was just
like she was the bot she was the drunk
you know like cousin who you just like
clearly scraping the bottom of the
barrel so when I was staying there I
thought something was up and what
happened was I not only they're not
handled that well but I felt guilty
about this for years Clint um you know
as a teenager so at this point I was 12
and I didn't spend a lot of time with my
grandma after that and it was because as
a kid every time I looked at her spend
time with her reminded me of him and
when she got sick and she was in the
hospital I regret it for years not
really visiting I just just it's no
excuse I was wrong but I wasn't able to
process it I just couldn't stand almost
couldn't it sounds a we'd almost
couldn't stand the sight of my grandma
because it reminded me of that and I
just it was blinding pain as a kid so I
don't listen I don't blame you at all I
would speak people react in different
ways well yeah and it's it is such an
unusual thing in one's life to to all of
a sudden
have somebody that you are close to and
you looked up to and admired and and
just a friend
you know it's for them to be gone it's
just like you said processing and all I
said you know I just don't do it well
and that's okay there are things in my
life I do well and and and you know like
playing Susan when she's CEO of YouTube
you do haha
yeah that was just like butter painting
with the fine brushes Michael yes
exactly you did it with aplomb okay I
haven't seen it and and it's really good
and and it's funny and you're good and I
don't know people might think that you
know like I immediately saw the thing
and I get a copy of it no no finally
finally I was able to look at it all and
when we were working together you were
explaining things to me that I was a
little dense about and I myself at the
same time going to does it make sense
what that make sense right I think it
makes sense the wonderful thing about
you Stephen is that you had a plan you
and I could tell that you aren't just
wildly aiming you know and firing in the
dark that you sort of had a design for
this thing which is what kind of a
writer does and anybody who does as much
talking as you do is a writer and well
you know that was all there was you and
some of the the you're always such a
dick that was hot I was all clear that
was all Clint and it was it was
sometimes that's the that's the Nuggets
is win some time to last almost random
here's what I get some satisfaction out
of Susan Wojcicki CEO of YouTube who is
as far left as they get trying to do the
social engineering knows you played her
in this and it has an IMDB profile so if
ever she gets our channel removed and
this has never seen again
at least we got that on her I do before
we go you mentioned something about
Johnny Depp with the memorial you had a
story well a couple of dads better roles
or bigger
or memorable roles were with Johnny Depp
and and I I know Johnny knew Johnny a
long time ago through Charlie Sheen we'd
worked together doing a short film that
Charlie directed and Johnny heard Johnny
and Tim Burton heard about dad dying and
Johnny contacted in fact well John has
the same agent that ron has so let it be
known that he you know he can't go but
he wants to send a clip right and you
know it was really cool that you know he
brought back the memories of Ed Wood
because that was they dad did a great
term in Ed Wood when he's you know he's
the investor in the movie in thought of
son he's a little slow but something
tells me he's gonna be a big-time star
or leading man right and it just killed
and Johnny's expression was great and
you know listen it's he's got the
ability to do it at his house and he get
it wherever he's living in France or
something and it was just nice and it he
talked a little bit a bit about him and
I'm working together and we it was as
eccentric in his off as you can imagine
with Charlie Sheen Johnny Depp and me I
can imagine yeah there's there's a hope
hopefully the NSA is not spying in on
that one because I can imagine some
Johnny Depp and
and a pilot they give stuff like that
big thumbs up yeah exactly they couldn't
care less they're good with it alright
listen mister what'd he do were you
gonna say something there because we do
have to get going this is uh we got more
so a philosophical it's fun okay you rag
you rag on China Dennis yeah well no
because that's pretty much just Jackie
Chan threatening you if you don't
support the Communist the Communist
Party and then making millions of
dollars in American films I'm done with
Jackie Chan by the way don't if you ever
work with him but he's actually he's
actually the essays for Chinese
communist propaganda he's actually done
it yeah I know I swear to you go good
just YouTube after this Jackie Chan PSA
yeah that's not a joke okay
all right on that note we have to go
Clint Howard left to have you back thank
you so much for being here and taking
the time hold on give us a dance
[Music]
where were you
that's your house where'd you go after
studio yeah what'd you do over there
gonna change my mind video about the
heart strike what about it
huh how come even tell me about the
hardest right huh doesn't know about it
[Music]
my video just left legs all down when
you when you fly :
would you fire you Shapiro Clavin for
its southern Dennis Prager you flip
Dennis Prager yeah yeah like Dennis
Prager everyone else has never been on
your channel but we gonna do my nothing
but a selfish fat pig selfish you better
let me take it for mother box
Joe if I see you put Jansen to play one
month on me
[Music]
[Music]
just oh my guy contact that's what he
wants great show good show
rich show razörfist and of course Clint
Howard we're going to have another
change my mind
coming up I'll be taping what about and
I'll sit the first year it's the first
of the universe one of the year yeah
little saying we haven't really known
any of big on location videos because we
did have to do a test run of the big
show that's at Virginia Tech by the way
some upcoming shows we're going to see
how many we're going to do with them but
SMU Illinois Alabama a few others
Liberty University we don't know exactly
when I think they start March 22nd we're
gonna rattle off a few live show so stay
tuned and it came off of something else
was talking oh we haven't yep so we'll
do it change my mind we're gonna tape a
bunch of them tomorrow so great at
university but I'm not going to tell
them we don't let people know they say
why don't you let me know you were in
might because I don't want people to
know I don't want to stack the deck no
against someone I want to actually have
a conversation I don't even need to just
put on a Groucho Marx kinda yeah
tweet us toots who is what the topics
you want to be covered is
interchangeable by the way speaking of
tweets you are correct
pineapples do not grow on trees they do
not ride sir it's almost as though I'm
from Canada coconuts I've seen coconuts
when we went to Hawaii people that's
relevant more than Canada same thing
with the same thing basically kill
people so um I correct myself I guess
they grow toward the ground have you
seen how a jackfruit those things are
viciously huge and spiky those do grow
on trees a little Apple called jackfruit
they call jackfruits and or maybe this
I'm think of durian I heard a spiky
little bastards a fallen tree I'm not
too big of a man to correct myself I had
no idea where pineapples came from I
didn't realize there was a big
difference between highbush blueberries
and lowbush blueberries like wild
blueberries some of them really really
sin which i get knots in they're really
just small in diameter and so they're
way more antioxidant rich the wild
blueberries a lot more fiber because the
skin is like thicker it's basically all
skin they're not as watery so when you
eat them they're more sour but they're
better for you I was a grown-ass man
before I realized there's difference
between regular grapes and concord
grapes i was always confused where they
got the grape mulches juice flavor and i
was disappointed that did not taste like
the grapes they were feeding me yeah
that's how to comment or greasy I don't
feel so bad about not knowing about
I know what did you think a Concord
grape was what do you think Congress
just came I didn't I didn't know what I
just thought it was just a just I don't
know you just thought Welch's and then
they're adding I don't know what I was
Danny that doesn't make any sense at all
my brain was a broken Saskatoon berries
give it a Saskatoon bay no they only
grow them all in Saskatchewan and now in
Michigan and it tastes like a middle
ground between a blueberry in an almond
funny thing about hopper hopper hates
blueberries loves Saskatoon berries if
our always doesn't know Roger pitching
the show to the Food Network's Network
it's gonna be Guy Fieri vodka so his own
so uh listen couple let me say I know it
was rare I dropped an f-bomb at the
beginning I listen I don't like doing
that on the show and we had the sensor
button ready thank God but it's not it's
not the way we want to do the show but
let me tell you something yeah I was
pissed and I tried to express myself in
more than only a few words unlike the
Young Turks where every word is the F
word and if you hear bleeps in the show
it's you limited vocabulary a very
limited sorry and you by the way doesn't
punctuate a sentence yeah that's why
people are tweeting that's what people
are sending a message like Oh Crowder
must be met because it's not every other
word sure someone who speaks that way
every single other word as you have with
Ana Kasparian or take it ceases to mean
something in Houston we talk about a lot
you know as Christians obviously you do
people talk about bad language well
obviously this idea of the Lord's name
in vain but bad language is really you
know spending swears in German and no
really considers it bad language III
swear in French all the time and you
guys like that usually
I usually giggle are usually giggle bad
words really only have the they were the
power that you ascribe to them that's
the truth with most words and that's
kinda some we've talked about words are
very very powerful words are very
powerful tool but they can also be
stripped of their power pretty easily
it's kind of like a Freddy Krueger he's
just not afraid of him he can't kill you
no I'm not making this huge for using a
bed we're because there's people out
there especially if you had kids
listening I apologize might be offended
but what's funny to me is when and this
whale would always happen in churches a
lot remember the sort of litmus test
they would use is naughty words but not
naughty actions see that people who
you'd never hear anything bad from you'd
have people who you would never say
anything that could be offensive but
they were cheating otherwise and I'm not
saying it's either/or or they were
siping because it's something really
obvious it's pretty obvious it's pretty
easy to fake when you're out in public
and speak nicely it's pretty easy to
pull in eddie haskill you know it's not
easy to fake good ideas if I were to say
what offends me and I'm not really
offended but if I would say what would
offends me intellectually far more than
someone saying a naughty word are ideas
that fly in the face of basic human
rights how about that bring me back to
that you know I don't want to talk about
too much with our guest we kind of
talked about it with razörfist but this
idea now that you're seeing of disarming
a populace we've seen what has happened
throughout history we've seen what has
happened when you strip people of their
basic rights and by the way they're all
intertwined this is what I find funny
when the left tries to say well look at
the trans bathroom it's just like the
civil rights era it's just like being
segregated fountains really first off I
don't think using a urinal or not using
alert urinal I guess going in a little
girl's room when you're a man haven't
even transitioned you put on a wig in a
dress
I don't really think necessarily even
your preference of friction is the same
as not being allowed to sit on the bus I
don't think it's comparable let me tell
you what I do think is comfortable what
offends me intellectually with ideas is
disarming a populace it's putting a
magazine capacity band making sure
people can't purchase semi-automatic
weapons a buyback that's mandatory that
you never tell people about I do think
that's comparable to the evil regimes of
days past matter of fact I think if
something that did directly so you can
be mad that I I told you to go button
that I told you to go shelf earlier but
you know what that's what you repeatedly
do and if it repeatedly happens to
anyone who pays attention to what's
happening politically these days it is a
constant assault of not just bad ideas
we talk about good ideas we talk about
bad ideas there are good ideas and there
are evil ideas and taking away the
ability for someone to protect
themselves for someone to defend life
and limb here's the thing people said
what would this person did something
horrible horrible heinous shooting no
one is excusing it same thing with Las
Vegas no one is excusing it of course
that's an act of evil but you don't
answer an act of evil with an act of
even greater evil they said well you
don't know what if this person is this
trip we can't let people go out we can't
let people have guns because we don't
know every situation we don't know who
they
I say hold on a second you can't bar
people from defending themselves because
you don't know everyone in every
situation it can go both ways we don't
know what if they take they're gonna
hurt somebody
what if somebody needs a gun because
they have a restraining order on a crazy
person who already raped them and we saw
that happen in New Jersey
what if somebody needs a gun because
they're living in a bad area of town and
they're traveling across town going to
school trying to make something of
themselves and so they need to protect
themselves at home maybe that's
something you might want to take into
account what if there's a mother whose
father died overseas and she needs to
protect her family right now while she
gets back on her feet maybe she needs a
gun because the only chance she has is
being more powerful than a man and it's
a mechanical advantage not a physical
one despite the both Krav Maga class you
taught her at the YMCA or WMC I have no
idea anymore
the point is when you say we don't know
we so let's just we don't know every
circumstance we agree here we go boom
common ground wait wait we can't know
everyone's reasoning for purchasing a
gun
absolutely so let's strip people of
their god-given right to protect
themselves no that's where we diverge
and that's all this conversation is
about you'll hear and if there's a
24-hour news cycle we were able to get
through this show and get you everything
you need you want to know what you need
to know it's really simple decide this
for yourself do you have the basic right
to self-preservation do you believe that
you're the god-given human right to
self-preservation we talk about civil
rights we talk about human rights I want
to get married that's not a human right
no one has a birthright of getting
married you have to find someone who's
willing to marry you first I want to use
the bathroom you don't have the right to
use anyone elses private bathroom they
can deny service at Starbucks but now
they can't do it if you've got a swing
and daughter or going into a ladies room
oh but I would no listen rights our
freedom of speech do you believe that
you have the right to protect that
speech do you believe that you have the
right to protect yourself your family
and your home guess what in 2018 that
includes the right to a gun
period do you believe you have the right
to protect yourself yes
then shut off the news because there's
nothing there that is of value to you
and if you're gonna be mad about my
words this appeal can looking you know
what I'm mad that
you want to kill people over up to three
million lives saved each year by the way
that's from guns being used proactively
that doesn't necessarily include the
number of people who simply vanish a gun
and it saves their life but you know
what one of our worldviews doesn't
require us to know every single
individual circumstance one of our
worldviews mind only requires that I
understand I could never possibly know
every individual circumstance and so
when you accept that you accept that
there's evil and you give people who
want to mess it up the tools to do so
so shut off the 24 hour cable news cycle
I don't care who's talking on a panel
the great canadian panel the great
American panel or the great Swiss panel
who's given us nothing and giving up a
whole long time ago I just recap the
issue for you there you go uncle Stephen
looking out for you go go you have
something to protect you have that you
have the right to protect yourself and
your field go spend time with your
family go enjoy it and stop listening to
the bull crap I'll see you next week
[Music]